pas
que
[Musique]
c'est parti pour un nouveau résumé de
l'actualité en moins de dix minutes en
france nouvelles règles du couvre feu à
compter de 18 heures à partir de ce
samedi objectif mettre un coup de frein
à la progression du variant britannique
[Musique]
la troisième vague de l'épidémie semble
inévitable
[Musique]
cinéma salle de théâtre ne rouvrirait
pas le 7 janvier que me rancourt procès
l'opposant russe alexeï navalni a été
arrêté dimanche c'est pas ma mission
mais c'est la mission de tout le monde
l'égalité
beyrouth
plongée dans le noir
[Musique]
la france a dépassé le seuil des cent
mille morts du cours navires us
journée historique aux états unis
d'où des caporaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais tu vois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
yuna wang ça y est joe biden et le
nouveau président des états unis que
marc roger frey chef donald trump refuse
toujours de reconnaître sa défaite vie
peut-être la dernière saison des états
unis
[Musique]
la réponse est non seize départements
français sont re confiné 7 jours sur 7
voulais rester sur une thématique plutôt
bonne ambiance
après le variant britannique le variant
sud africain le variant brésilien
nouveaux variants vient d'être découvert
en bretagne invariants breton variant
bretonnes et bretons les parents autant
l alfa venus d'angleterre voici le delta
air de nous sommes entrés dans une
quatrième vague du virus
je pense que la réponse est relativement
mal
cela fait plus de dix mois qui suivent
quasiment tous leurs cours à distance la
précarité étudiante s'est renforcée
interne il ya une détresse sociale qui
est dimensionné 'très économique' une
détresse psychologique il ya des jeunes
qui vont à faire des collectes
alimentaires tous les jours pour aller à
s'alimenter il ya des jeunes qui mettent
fin à leurs jours c'est tous les jours
cette distribution assez tous les jours
et plusieurs fois par jour ou aux dons
mais je vais me faire [ __ ] il nous
reste sept trouve le gouvernement a fait
des promesses mais ça ne suffit pas il
faut assumer pleinement la fonction
alors ma réponse est non je vais veiller
à ce que les choses soient très claires
il vous fait parler quand tout va bien
est ce que cette anecdote est vrai ou
faux c'est vraiment en bon français un
coup dans le dos le président emmanuel
macron réfléchit à un pass sanitaire
passe sanitaire sera étendu le pass and
it erp à sony de bastad monétaire
finiront en bagarre de saloon c'est le
plus gros poisson d'avril de l'histoire
de ces dix ou quinze vingt dernières
années c'est du grand n'importe quoi la
réponse à la question est ce que je me
fais vacciner là évidemment oui ça y est
tu vacciner je veux bien relié où on est
haut de l'épidémie aujourd'hui je crains
que l'on va continuer d'entendre
d'accueil 19 dans la décennie qui vient
jeudi la question suivante
[Musique]
ça y est c'est la fin du déconfinement
en france
nous allons lever l'obligation port du
masque l'extérieur en été on va pouvoir
respirer à pleins
les bars les cafés et les restaurants
vous pouvoir rouvrir leurs terrasses la
joie de se retrouver c'est le
soulagement du côté des cafetiers des
restaurateurs et les boîtes de nuit vont
rouvrir le 9 juillet après plus de
quinze mois de fermeture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
elle est là elle est là la victoire
n'hésitez pas de cadeau aujourd'hui ma
victoire vaut mieux
[Musique]
jours de match et s'est fait plaisir
on peut pas rester calmes et oui c'est
très content de ce qui se passe ce soir
j'ai envie de vous dire y avoir du sport
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
houplines
[Applaudissements]
j'avais des choses initial est une des
frissons en regardant cette vidéo
vraiment un cheval qui ne veut pas y
aller elle seule médaille d'or qui
manque m
dans la
foulée
il faudra être là
j'étais beaucoup chambrer mais c'est ma
méthode c'est j'ai senti que j'avais un
peu troublé cette jeune femme je quitte
définitivement la vie publique
on se dit juste qu'on se moque de nous
nombreuses femmes se font violer ce bon
violent avec des guillemets il nous faut
cet instant quand c'est une femme qui
crie de lui venir en soutien qu'elle
soit transgenres ou 6
1 % des plaintes pour viol aboutisse à
un procès aux assises
oh mais bon il ya des ong comme action
contre la faim qui ouvre dès qu'ils
ouvrent des actions d'urgence pour
résoudre des problèmes aux quatre coins
du monde y compris en france 27
personnes ont péri après le naufrage de
leur embarcation dans la banque il
s'agit en fait du drame migratoire le
plus meurtrier depuis 2018 ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui est une injustice
profonde
[Musique]
une attaque à l'aéroport de kaboul et
l'afghanistan en état d' alerte
j'ai besoin de connaître l'enchaînement
exact ses vêtements
le giec publie aujourd'hui son nouveau
rapport sur le changement climatique
l'homme est bien le responsable du
changement climatique sûrement une
claque
on pourrait dépasser les 50 de grippe
c'est pas le pitch d'une nouvelle série
netflix
c'est l' alerte rouge pour le climat et
comme my world
[Musique]
celle de ben sylla pas du monde et que
ces images impressionnantes de
la planète fonce vers la catastrophe
tiens où tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
c'est
ça donne à la fois le vertige et ça fait
rêver
elle va commencer oui ça a commencé
[Musique]
on nous donne envie de partir avec sa
femme ont pu quoi
[Musique]
sujet dont on va beaucoup entendre
parler dans les mois à venir élections
présidentielles en france la dynamique
et l'on s'est beaucoup s'y attendaient
la fiche de cette élection se précise
organisant une primaire de la gauche
fait pas une affaire d'ego je ne suis
plus le journaliste l'écrivain oui mais
au delà de ça nous avons besoin d'un
débat serein et notre côté on a une
mission évidemment continuer à vous
informer au mieux que souhaiter bonne
chance ces questions
bref merci pour votre fidélité merci
pour votre confiance cette année l'année
était très chargé niveau actualité la
suivante devrait l'être aussi évidemment
vous le savez on sera là avec vous pour
[Musique]